Republicans are finally on the verge of
a breakthrough president Trump has a
strategy to deal with Robert Mueller the
Democrats are trying to defend Al
Franken and I will have a full and
complete breakdown of star wars complete
with spoilers but don't worry I'll do
that near the end of the show I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
oh yes I have so many thoughts on the
new Star Wars film I cannot even begin
to explain so many thoughts indeed and I
will get to all of them a little bit
later in the program we will also talk
about president Trump and finally it
seems has the Democrats on their heels
it's the end of the year and Democrats
don't really seem to know quite what to
do we'll talk about all that in just a
second but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at ring.com so rigs
mission is to make neighborhoods safer
today over a million people use the
amazing ring video doorbell we use it in
our house it is great it helps keep my
house safe one of the reasons is
whenever I'm out of town somebody rings
the doorbell the way people rob homes
typically is they ring the doorbell see
if you're home and then if you're not
they break in I can pick up the ring
from my phone or I can be in the middle
of the the other coast and I can pick up
my phone and I can talk to the person
and make it look like I am at home I can
also activate an alarm if I think that
they're robbing my house this is what
ring does for you and just like they're
amazing doorbell they know how a
floodlight cam and their floodlight
Kevin's a motion-activated camera and
floodlight that connects right to your
phone HD video two-way audio that lets
you know the moment anyone steps on your
property see it and speak to visitors
even set off an alarm right from your
phone with rings floodlight Kim when
things go bump in the night you'll
immediately know what it is whether
you're home or away the ring floodlight
cam lets you keep an eye on your home
from anywhere and right now you can save
up to a hundred and fifty dollars off a
ring of security kit when you go to
ring.com slash pendants rings comm slash
Ben again 150 bucks off that ring up
security kit keeps your family safe
keeps your home safe
great technology a lot of people are
using it now not just me and we've
bought additional ring products for our
home because it's so great ring up
security kit one hundred fifty bucks off
at ring comm / Ben that is ring calm and
slash venues the slash bends they know
that we sent you okay so we begin today
with the with the latest on the Mueller
investigation so it now appears that
Robert Mueller the special investigator
into Trump Russia collusion he's
obtained tens of thousands of Trump
transition emails now you may ask what
exactly do the Trump transition emails
have to do with collusion during the
election cycle the answer of course is
nothing but this is sort of the problem
for the Mueller investigation which
seems to be falling apart pretty quickly
all of the crimes they are now
investigating have to do the secondary
crimes lying to the FBI
maybe transition stuff but nothing to do
with that central contention
right the Trump and the Russians work
together to rig the 2016 elections
against Hillary Clinton this was the
entire motivating factor behind the
investigations in 2016 there's been the
entire reasons I'm across have been so
animated about it now so Special Counsel
Mueller has obtained many tens of
thousands of Trump transition emails
including emails from Jared Kushner
transition team sources told Axios Trump
officials discovered Mueller had the
emails when his prosecutors used them as
the basis for questions to witnesses the
sources said the emails included twelve
accounts one of which contain about
7,000 emails the accounts include the
team's political leadership and foreign
policy team according to the sources
apparently Mueller did this perfectly
legally he went through the GSA the
General Services Administration they
host the transition email system and
they have capacity to read all these
emails the transition emails are
included include sensitive exchanges on
matters that include potential
appointments gossip about the views of
particular senators involved in the
confirmation processes speculation about
vulnerabilities of Trump nominees etc
what does that have to do with collusion
the answer is pretty much nothing and
meanwhile while Mueller is going after
Trump over supposed collusion that we
have no evidence exists we now know that
the Obama administration was colluding
with Russia to help Iran so this is a
story out of Politico European version a
pretty amazing story reported this over
at Daily wire today there's clear
evidence that the Obama administration
colluded with the Russian government to
frame Islamic terrorists responsible for
the deaths of Americans in order to
appease Iran to pave the way for the
Obama administration's 'iron nuclear
deal there's a report from Josh Meyer of
Politico then it reports that a leaf a
god a Lebanese an arms dealer and quote
suspected top cause bola operative whom
agents believed reported to Russian
President Vladimir Putin was captured by
the Czechs in 2014 Fayed had been
incited in the US now you would expect
the Obama administration to move for him
to be extradited correct nothing of the
sort the Obama administration did not
push for extradition instead Fayed ended
up in Lebanon where he's back at his
terrorist work he's particularly active
in supplying weapons to the barbarous
Syrian regime that's not the only thing
the Obama administration did on behalf
of Lebanese terrorists according to the
Politico administration officials also
blocked or undermined their efforts to
go after other top hezbollah operatives
and when project Cassandra agents and
other investigators sought repeatedly to
investigate and prosecute Abdullah Sofia
Dean
Hezbollah's longtime envoy to iran who
may considered the linchpin of hezbollah
as criminal network the Justice
Department refused in other words the
Obama administration was working with
the Russian government to make sure that
there was no crackdown on Hezbollah
because they were afraid it would tick
off the Russians we also know President
Obama was offering flexibility to the
Russians in the middle of the 2012
election saying that he had flexibility
after the election cycle if Putin would
just back off all of his concerns about
missile defense for the moment all of
which is to say there's a lot more
evidence of actual Russian collusion
among the Obama administration members
than there is among the Trump
administration members at this point at
least with regard to elections and even
with regard to policy because it turns
out that even what Mike Flynn was trying
to do ie get Russia to not push a
resolution at the UN condemning Israel
didn't work so the actual evidence of
collusion is basically nil which means
that Trump has the upper hand now in the
investigation apparently Trump is is
pretty sanguine about it there's a
report out today the Trump expects
Mueller to basically clear Trump himself
in the very near future and that's why
Trump said over the weekend he was asked
are you gonna fire Mueller and here was
his answer the president last night
quashed Capitol Hill rumors that he was
poised to fire special counsel Robert
Muller what else
what are you surprised okay so he's
obviously angry at the press for saying
then he's gonna fire Mueller as well he
should be and I think that he's right
when he says you know are you surprised
like guys I know you want me to do it
I'm not gonna do it why should he do it
Mueller's investigation has already been
compromised by the people who are inside
of it
it's already been shown to be at least
in part political or at least there are
those suspicions there's not evidence
that he did anything so why would he
fire Miller why not just wait it out
there's a question I asked on Friday why
not just wait this out and it appears
the president has come to the same
conclusion especially because it appears
the president is now winning on a series
of subjects tax cuts are supposed to be
voted on tomorrow in the House and the
Senate
so we will have a tax reform bill before
Christmas that tax reform bill does
lower taxes for virtually everyone in
the United States including corporations
you may have quibbles with the way that
it's structured I have quibbles with it
too it is a good bill it also gets rid
of the individual mandate as it
currently stands that means you will not
be mandated to buy your crappy Obamacare
program anymore the left says well
that's terrible because now people are
gonna lose their health insurance well
the people losing their health insurance
are people who don't want to buy their
health insurance according to the
Congressional Budget Office so this is a
big win for Trump if this happens it's
sort of partial repeal of Obamacare
included in the tax reform and Trump
obviously is very excited there's a
report out today that the last quarters
growth has been revised upward to almost
four percent of GDP growth which is an
amazing level of growth haven't had that
in years here as President Trump talking
about that yesterday the economy now has
hit 3% nobody thought would be anywhere
close I think we can go to four or five
and maybe even 6% ultimately each
percentage point is two and a half
trillion dollars we are back we're
really going to start to rock we need
this as our final push and you're going
to see some numbers that are great but
most importantly you're going to see
great job numbers jobs are gonna come
pouring back into this country which we
need very much okay so there has been
you know there there having good
quarters before there was a good quarter
in q3 of 2014 for example we've heard
something like five percent but if Trump
has the sustained level of growth he's
gonna do just fine or at least he's
gonna be in better shape and he knows it
he knows it and that's why you're seeing
all the Republicans come out now and say
well let the investigation
Ford who cares just let the
investigation do what the investigation
is gonna do no biggie right GOP senator
Lankford from I believe is from Oklahoma
he comes forward and he says yeah well
there's no reason to attend this
investigation at this point yeah it's
very serious we will have someone inside
what they've got to determine is was he
directing the investigation one way or
the other while he was on the
investigation is that something that can
go back and repair and look and see if
there's any kind of bias that's in it
obviously I don't think it taints the
entire process but it certainly takes
taints that season of it and it's
something you should look at with any
political investigation that he was on
at the time and the good news for
President Trump is that even if the
investigation goes badly for him at this
point it's been so politicized that
there's gonna be a bevy of people who
come out and say this thing is just to
political Jeanine Pirro of course will
lead the way on Fox News
she says that the FBI agents involved
should be jailed now this is over the
top but it's also the angle a lot of
people are gonna take no matter how this
investigation goes it all started when
Cardinal Comey destroyed our FBI with
political hacks to set events in motion
to destroy the Republic because they
didn't like the man we chose to be our
president well it's time to take them
out in cups okay so this is obviously
over the top from Jeanine Pirro but
there will be a lot of people who do who
do sort of say this right who move in
this direction and Trump knows it so
Trump has the upper hand now he has the
upper hand on policy it's the end of the
year and it appears he's actually to get
some things done he knows the
investigation doesn't seem like it's
going anywhere and so the Democrats are
panicked in a second I'm gonna talk
about the insane media bias being
exhibited in pursuit of President Trump
and it really is insane and how they're
they're exploding all over themselves
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at thrive market so I'm
somebody who believe it or not likes to
eat healthy now that doesn't mean I
enjoy healthy food very often I don't or
at least I didn't until I started using
thrive market so thrive market not only
has the best organic food the best
organic kosher vegan food they also have
it cheaper than anyplace else with one
click of a button you can sort thrive
markets catalog by 90 values based on
your dietary needs from vegan
gluten-free paleo non-gmo and yes
kosher they cut out the middleman for
the first time in history you don't have
to go to Whole Foods and and stand in
line and pay expensive prices you don't
have to worry about driving
that Prius guy who won't get out of the
way in the parking lot with the gore
bumper sticker from mm all you're gonna
have to do is go online to thrive market
and get your favorite products less
expensive and just as good right or
better then you would at your local
health food store they also have a hyper
curated catalogue so instead of going to
your local health food store and finding
fifteen super expensive almond butters
now at thrive market they do their
homework for you they pick the three or
four best almond butters on thrive
market and you know its source from the
best of the best ingredients at the most
affordable prices
they also have supplements protein
powders and more right all of the things
that you don't like to use if you like
to exercise a lot as I do you can you're
spending up to fifty percent more on
top-notch organic products for me it
makes a lot of sense because again I
keep kosher so this means I can actually
eat from their catalogue for all my
listeners my friends at thrive market
are now offering you 60 bucks of free
groceries plus free shipping and a
30-day free trial so it's an awesome
deal that's equivalent to a bunch a
bunch of organic products I mean a bunch
of vegan kosher healthy product $60 of
free groceries plus free shipping and a
30-day free trial all for switching to
thrive market for your online grocery
needs keep in mind thrash prices are
already twenty five to fifty percent
below retail and now they're offering
you that extra sixty bucks of free
groceries it's are pretty awesome deal
go to thrive market calm slash Shapiro
to get your instant 60 bucks of free
groceries
again that's thrive market calm slash up
hero to get that instant 60 bucks of
free groceries thrive market dot-com
slash Shapiro I mean that's an amazing
offer 60 bucks of free groceries and
free shipping and a 30-day free trial
that's as good as it can be check it out
again thrive market calm / appear use
that slash up hero so they know that we
sell okay so the media are beginning to
pick up on the fact that President Trump
actually is in not terrible shape
going into 2018 now the Congress the
Congress could be in terrible shape
going into 2018 and Trump could be in
good shape
right and this is sort of the problem
that you're seeing for president Trump
is true for President Obama also so
Trump tweeted out this morning that you
shouldn't you shouldn't take
congressional losses as a referendum on
him right here's what he said remember
Republicans are five and no in
congressional races this year well
doesn't count Senate races the media
refuses to mention this I said go
lesbian more would lose for very
different reasons and they did I also
predicted I would win I don't know why
eyes and scare quotes there again the
president needs a remedial course on
scare quotes Republicans will do well in
2018 very well and so I mean number one
I guess this is a prediction that we can
now take to the bank
because he's good at predicting things
as the president but this idea that
Congress is gonna go well because Trump
is going well is not really accurate
that said Trump's accomplishments this
year are greater than they appeared like
they were going to be safe three months
ago right not only do we have gore since
we've have twelve appellate court
nominees who have been confirmed we have
a tax bill that looks like it's gonna go
through repeal of the individual mandate
on foreign policy the movement of the
embassy to Jerusalem the kickback
against the Iran nuclear deal the
president is moving I mean there's no
question that the Trump and Congress
aren't moving they're moving slower than
I would like this is their their first
real major legislative accomplishment
will be this tax reform but it is a
major accomplishment for him and he
needs it badly right now the poll on the
on the tax bills are not great right
there's a new Monmouth poll out today
showing 26% approve 47% disapprove 50%
think their own taxes will go up versus
14% we stay down you know why that is
that's because of the media and this is
why when President Trump groups the
media I think that would be wonderful
or the president would stick to the
facts because there are so many reasons
to dislike how the media cover these
things the media is suggesting that
people's taxes are going to go up is
insane factually speaking the vast
majority of human beings in the United
States would get a tax cut the media
keeps saying this is skewed toward the
wealthy well what do you expect non
wealthy people don't pay taxes in the
United States in fact is middle class
upper class people those are the people
play taxes and by and large it's upper
class people who pay taxes people who
don't make a lot of money do not pay
income tax in the United States so you
think they're gonna get a major tax
break but all this business information
does have an impact but what's amazing
about this is the media do not
understand why their credibility is
going down now the media have basically
expended their credibility to get Trump
this is the trade they've been willing
to make they're going to go out on a
limb and say untrue things plainly
untrue things in an effort to stop
President Trump and then they're
surprised when no one takes them
seriously and they're angry that Fox
continues to dominate the ratings and
they continue to call Fox
again a network brian Stelter on CNN
yesterday for example he says yo Fox
they talk like propagandists over at Fox
so like a propaganda network Kurt what
is going on here well I think you're
seeing exactly that Fox News has
basically become de facto state-run
propaganda it's at state controlled
state-run television that is beginning
excuse directly from the White House I
don't know how anyone can look at what's
going on right now and not reach that
termination Trump is not as if the White
House is literally running Fox are you
saying they are well if you look at the
coverage it seems like they are they
have gone so far Jim I remember the days
Brian when what you saw on pages like
Breitbart were considered the fringe it
was considered so far beyond the
mainstream not even Fox News would touch
what was on those pages now Fox is going
almost further than Breitbart and you
have right now at this second there's an
ad running in different markets with Fox
News contributor Tommy Lauren advocating
and this and attacking the Miller
investigation okay so you know I like
Kurt but when Kurt does this in CNN
humours it then this is a pot-kettle
situation okay CNN suggesting that other
networks are involved in propaganda let
me just show you a panel that was
talking about President Trump and
misogyny okay if this does not look like
propaganda to you then I don't know what
what would do you agree with Mike that
this has helped Kirsten Gillibrand I do
the one piece I disagree with is that
President Trump if this was a one-off
that would be one thing but this is a
guy who was misogynist DNA who ran as a
misogynist I'm sure that wasn't on his
bumper sticker but that was part of who
he was and who he ran as so this is
completely aligned with that that's why
people heard what they heard from the
tweet Jen Psaki CNN political
commentator also the former State
Department spokesperson for Barack Obama
it but they're not a propaganda network
right it's not propaganda when Fareed
Zakaria over at CNN says that the
Republican tax plan is uh showing a
bleak future right the universe is gonna
end because of Republican tax plans the
medium and long term effects of the plan
are clear a massive drop in public
investment which will come on the heels
of decades of declining spending as a
percentage of GDP on infrastructure
scientific research skills training and
core government agencies the United
States
cannot coast on past investments forever
and with this legislation we are
assuring in a bleak future really we're
ushering in a bleak future because I get
to keep more of my own money and I love
this idea that we're gonna stop spending
where the spending cuts I'm missing the
spending cuts yeah there are no spending
cuts this is one of the problems with
the bill right I would prefer there be
spending cuts this idea that oh well we
definitely need more money for for
infrastructure we definitely need more
money for for scientific research right
that that's really where the cuts are
happening here what is he talking about
if there are cuts those cuts are going
to come in the form of Medicare or
Medicaid or Social Security right that's
where the real spending is occurring
it's not occurring in the off-brand
spending categories the big spending in
the United States 66% of the federal
budget two-thirds of the federal budget
is consumed by Medicare Medicaid Social
Security that's where restructuring
needs to take place but you wonder why
the media is losing credibility at the
same time they're attacking the tax plan
as the end of the world
Americans have a bad opinion of this
because the media still has power now
this is one area where I think the right
is wrong you know the right has been
saying for years well you know we now
have the upper hand nobody listens to
the media anymore people have stopped
listening to the media on their
character descriptions when the media
say that Trump is a racist sexist
bigoted homophobic the American people
largely just ignore because they'll make
their own judgment on that when it comes
to the material and Bill's the American
people don't have time to read in 1,000
page tax bill and they tend to take the
talking points they see on the TV so if
you just watch Fareed Zakaria what you
would assume is that the Republicans
just cut spending by an enormous
percentage as opposed to cutting taxes
by an enormous percentage because
nowhere in there does Fareed Zakaria
talk about what actually happens to your
taxes a tax plan is about tax reduction
a spending plan would be about spending
reduction there's nothing about spending
in the tax plan but it just demonstrates
again you know the left wants to say Fox
is a propaganda outlet
listen Fox has its land but the media
have their own slant and President Trump
is not wrong to knock the media slant on
all of this the media have been
imploding and destroying their own
credibility on this stuff for quite a
while so it's not a tremendous shock to
see that President Trump is is surviving
and not only will he survive it appears
it appears the Moller investigation is
not really gonna go anywhere if that
happens you're gonna watch the media
implode and this sets up a sea
is problem for Democrats a really
serious problem for Democrats it sets up
a problem that the Democrats have set up
outsized expectations for their own for
their own party I don't need the entire
Democratic base believes that Trump is
on the verge of falling over if you talk
to a Democrat it sounds like Trump is
gonna be impeached tomorrow or Trump is
going to resign tomorrow or Trump is
going to die tomorrow this is how
Democrats talk Keith Olbermann said this
when he resigned well my job as here has
done because it turns out that President
Trump he's going to leave right now
like they're talking this nonsense for a
weapon and they're making it seem as
though they're on the verge of
impeaching President Trump but the truth
is they have no intention of doing any
of those things they're not going to
impeach President Trump because it would
not be politically beneficial for them
to impeach President Trump if they were
to move against President Trump Trump
would actually gain in the polls the
same way that Bill Clinton gained in the
polls in 1998 when the Republicans moved
for impeachment if they were to go after
Trump unfairly there would be a rally
round the Trump effect it's the opposite
of what they want and so the Democrats
are now stuck between a rock and a hard
place they have been promising that
Trump's agenda is going to fail it's not
they have been promising the president
Trump is going to leave office and
ignominious disgrace not that he's not
gonna be reelected but that he's going
to have to resign due to financial
impropriety corruption collusion with
the Russians that's not going to happen
either and the Democrats are beginning
to sense that they are in serious
trouble here the Democrats are beginning
to sense that if they push this thing
too hard there could be a real problem
for them so Doug Jones the recently
elected senator from Alabama Democrat he
was asked should President Trump be
should he resign over sexual harassment
allegations and Doug Jones knows there's
gonna be blowback to him and other
Democrats if they push this way so
here's Jake Tapper rightly pressing him
on it and Doug Jones basically saying no
we're gonna leave Trump in place where I
am on that right now is that those
allegations were made before the
election and so people had an
opportunity to judge before that
election I think we need to move on and
not get distracted by those issues let's
get on with the real issues that are
facing people of this country right now
and and I don't think that the president
ought to resign at this point we'll see
how things go but certainly those
allegations are not new and he was
elected with those allegations at front
center and remember Nancy Pelosi came
out and said she was not going to
support impeachment right now
major Democrats
saying they're not gonna support
impeachment in fact major Democrats
sound like they want to try and work
with Trump because they know that Trump
may not be going anywhere okay the
incumbent always has a major advantage
going into a presidential election so
Democrats have sold their base a bill of
goods and matt is going to come home to
them in a serious way it could seriously
in 2020 I'll explain why in just a
second but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at Dollar Shave
Club so you've heard me talk about the
great shave that I get right here under
my chinny chin chin for my Dollar Shave
Club razor especially when I use their
dr. Carver's shave butter well I'm not
gonna give up my membership not only am
I not gonna give up my membership
I've actually expanded my portfolio of
products that I use from Dollar Shave
Club because they don't just have
products for shaving they also have
products for your hair your face your
skin showering they have everybody who
uses them feeling and looking great it
is all their own original stuff they use
the finest premium ingredients they
deliver it right to you just like they
do their razors so no more annoying
trips to the store where you have to
decide whether to buy the brand or
off-brand shampoo instead Dollar Shave
Club just sends you the best stuff
they've got me covered head-to-toe and
with gift memberships and gift cards
available that can help cover the names
on your holiday shopping list as well I
want you to love Dollar Shave Club as
much as I do so I have arranged for you
to get a special deal you get to try
your first month of their best razor
alone with travel sized versions of
their shave butter their body cleanser
and yes their world-famous butt wipes
for just five bucks after that there are
placement cartridges ship for just a few
bucks a month
it's the DSE starter set get yours for
just $5 exclusively at
dollarshaveclub.com
slash Ben again that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben and when
you use the slash pen you get five
dollar startup set and you get your
first month of their best razor along
with travel sized versions of shea
butter body cleanser and the butt wipes
for five bucks pretty great deal so go
over to dollarshaveclub.com slash pen
get started today never worry about
being clean and looking good again okay
so here is the problem for the Democrats
they've made all of these big promises
to their base Trump is gonna go we've
got him on the ropes he's on the verge
of falling apart what happens if they
don't deliver what happens if they don't
deliver what happens if they start
moving the long lines of Tim Ryan Tim
Ryan is a Democrat and Democratic
Representative from Ohio who says that
he may want to work with President Trump
now what happens if the Democrats decide
to be practical instead of feeding the
pie-in-the-sky frenzy that the Bernie
bros won
or the Hillary or the Hillary Heller
harridans are interested in here's Tim
Ryan explaining that he'd like to work
with the President and then what I'm
saying is that this isn't gonna do it
President Bush said cut taxes on the
wealthiest it's gonna lead to growth
wages are gonna go up that in two
thousand one two and three that was the
the decade with the least amount of
growth we've had since the Great
Depression and what I'm saying is we
need to take down to lappa dated homes
we need that we need that
trillion-dollar infrastructure bill that
the president promised how in God's name
are we gonna pay for that if we're
borrowing two trillion dollars from
China to do the taxes okay what if Trump
comes forward early next year with his
giant infrastructure plan or what if he
calls their bluff what if he says listen
I spent it on the taxes okay the tax
bill it's done now you owning your
infrastructure bill I'm gonna give it to
you
what did Democrats do do they embrace
him do they run away from him or did
they do what Bernie Sanders does Bernie
Sanders gonna be the only intellectually
coherent Democrat he says he's gonna
vote against the tax cuts and then he
says he'll vote for the infrastructure
bill with the knowledge that if
Democrats retake Congress they'll have
to raise taxes is that a winning plan
Trump may have the Democrats in a bit of
a trap here because if he cuts taxes and
people see a little bit more money in
their in their mailbox and it turns out
their taxes didn't go up they went down
and my taxes I'm one of the few people
in America whose taxes will go up in all
likelihood thanks to the Trump bill but
most people will have a tax reduction if
you have that tax reduction and then
Trump comes along says I want the
infrastructure bill and Democrats vote
with him on infrastructure that puts
them in the position of now having to
argue that they want to raise your taxes
again is that a winning political
argument does this sound like a winning
political argument from Bernie Sanders
but if you Democrats take control our
corporate taxes going up I think we're
going to take a very hard look at this
entire tax bill and make it a tax bill
that works for the middle class and
working families not for the top one
percent at large multinational
corporations but there's no question
that in order to achieve all of the
things you want Texas are gonna have to
go up on corporations if they're down to
21 as a result of this legislation you
can't find the money anywhere absolutely
yes so okay in my view absolutely okay
so amazing right Trump may have them
boxed in because he's actually decreased
the the tax revenue and increased the
spending forcing Democrats the Democrats
who embraced
increase spending and also to embrace an
increase in taxes now here's the problem
for Democrats if they're trapped this
way and if they don't move against Trump
if they don't try to impeach the
president what do they do next where do
they go you could easily see a Democrat
in 2020 running on a primary ballot or
this Ben's ominous is appointed the
Federalist I think it's a good one could
easily see Democrats going so crazy that
Trump is still in office in 2020 but
they decide to nominate a Dennis
Kucinich type all right some actual nut
case they decide to nominate somebody so
crazy far to the left that the guy is
pledging the moon and then that person
goes crazy during the election cycle and
they lose to Trump again right you can
see Trump winning re-election on the
back of this now listen none of this is
to say that Trump has the upper hand in
2018 okay because the statistics just
don't back that up but if Democrats
think that Trump is just going to fade
into the woodwork they've got another
thing coming especially because the
Democrats can't even get their own house
in order there's a story out today that
four Democratic senators now want to
keep Al Franken remember two weeks ago
when the Democrats were saying that they
wanted the moral high ground on sexual
harassment and sexual abuse that was
predicated on the notion that Roy Moore
was gonna win that Senate seat in
Alabama he did not win that Senate seat
now Obama and so now the Democrats are
left basically with their pants around
their feet because what do they do they
can have the moral high ground but
they're gonna have to oust their guy and
the Republicans don't have the moral low
ground anymore because they didn't
embrace more so what exactly did the
Democrats do so now the Democrats are
trying to walk it back the Democrats
don't want to be in a position of
calling on Trump to resign number one
and number two Democrats don't actually
want to lose half their senators because
of sexual harassment allegations when
the Republicans don't have to do the
same thing remember Roy Moore lost so it
doesn't look like the Republicans
support sexual abuse and harassment okay
so that's actually a political win in
some ways for the Republicans so now
there are four separate Democratic
senators who are saying they want Al
Franken to stay because they're afraid
of the precedent that this is going to
set showing once again that as I said
two weeks ago this is not about seizing
the world of high ground it was about
seizing the political high ground the
Democrats now think they don't have the
political high ground
so they want Franken reinstated okay Joe
Manchin of West Virginia he said quote
what they did to Elle was atrocious the
Democrats he said it's the most
hypocritical thing I've ever seen done
to a human being and then have enough
guts to sit on the floor watching him
give his speech and go over and hug him
that's hypocrisy at the highest level
I've ever seen my life made
me sick pat leahy they're not case
Democrat from Vermont he had called for
Franken to leave
apparently he secretly told Franken he
regrets doing so two other senators who
sided against Franken have apparently
told political they'd like to see Frank
can stay so now the Democrats are trying
to rehabilitate this guy who's
photographed nearly grabbing a woman's
boobs and has been apparently alleged
multiple times to grab women by the but
now they're trying to rehabilitate that
guy so Democrats are a mess they're
unbelievably enough Chris Matthews has
now been caught up in the sexual
harassment scandal there are allegations
that Chris Matthews I was there they say
pants settle in tougher employee
apparently what happened isn't according
to Daily Caller Chris Manning I got up
in the morning tell me they show when in
the office he said a bunch of sexist
things to women unbelievable this is
what it said this is what they said over
on over on NBC according to NBC News NBC
paid severance to a female staffer in
1999 who accused Chris Matthews of
sexual harassment Matthews was making
inappropriate jokes and comments to this
female staffer in front of other people
NBC News reported that a confidentiality
agreement could not reveal the amount
given to the staffer but the Daily
Caller reported that it was $40,000 and
I'm as NBC spokesperson told NBC News
that during that time when the matter
was brought up Matthews also received a
formal reprimand for what he did
alrighty so now Chris Matthews is in
trouble and now it turns out that Linda
Sarsour shock of shock is in trouble
there's a story out today again the
Democrats set this standard because they
wanted the moral high ground and they
won the political high ground on sexual
harassment and now they're gonna have to
get rid of it because all of their own
people are getting caught in the net
according to the New York Post
controversial Muslim activists and
women's March organized a Linda Sarsour
bullied in underling to cover up sex
abuse allegations in her Brooklyn office
ask me falfa Bob told the Daily Caller
that a man repeatedly rubbed his crotch
on her while she worked for the
Association under Saur Saur in 2009 but
when faithful Babb reported the abuse
Saur Saur a self-proclaimed feminist and
co-founder of the women's march
organization fat shamed the woman and
threatened a blacklist her from
political jobs the woman told the
website
well she oversaw an environment unsafe
and abusive to women women who puts our
store on a pedestal from women's rights
and empowerment deserve to know how she
really treats us apparently
they the Daily Caller spoke with a bunch
of other people about this and they
confirmed it so it appears that women's
March organizer and feminist icon Linda
Sarsour was involved in all of this so
the Democrats are now gonna have to give
up the moral high ground to regain the
political high ground and the irony is
just too rich it'll be hilarious if Al
Franken is the most well known sexual
abuser in the Senate after Roy Moore
loses his Alabama Senate race and the
Democrats end up with the egg on their
face for having to re embrace a guy who
they threw overboard five seconds ago
well in just a second I want to talk
about the things I like and things I
hate but you know I want to actually
reverse that today so the way that I'm
gonna do things today because because I
have such a long take on Star Wars is I
want to start with our discussion of the
Federalist Papers so typically we do the
Federalist Papers at the end of the show
but now we're gonna do the Federalist
Papers a little bit earlier so we've
been doing a Federalist paper every week
we're now up to Federalist number 8 so
Federalist number 8 was written by
Alexander Hamilton and Alexander
Hamilton in this Federalist paper
discusses at length how American wars
would be more bloody than European Wars
this is his excuse for saying that
America needs to be and it needs to be
one country as opposed to too many so
here is is what Alexander Hamilton says
he says in this country the scene would
be altogether reversed he says that we'd
be more bloody than European wars
because in Europe you have a bunch of
small standing armies that basically
fight one another but they don't
threaten civil liberties he says war in
America would be a lot more comedy says
in this country the scene would be all
together reversed the jealousy of
military establishments would postpone
them as long as possible
the lawns of fortifications leaving the
frontiers of one state open to another
would facilitate inroads the populous
states would with little difficulty
overrun their less populous neighbors
conquests would be as easy to be made as
difficult to be retained war therefore
would be to solitary and predatory
plunder and devastation ever marched in
the Train of irregular the calamities of
individual would make the principal
figure in the events which would
characterize our military exploits in
other words he says that if there were
ever to be wars inside the United States
they would be supremely bloody of course
Alexander Hamilton ended up being right
the bloodiest war in American history is
still the civil war he said also that
risk of invasion the possibility that
your state's going to be invaded by
neighbouring state would make people
less free because we create standing
armies now the founders were really
skeptical of standing armies the
founders were were not happy with the
idea of a professional army that was a
huge percentage of the population they
understood that there might be a need
for a small professional army but the
idea of a standing army that was going
to basically be quartering itself in
people's homes or there's a big draft
this is not something they were in love
with Alexander Hamilton says the risk of
invasion would make people less free he
said quote the violent destruction of
life and property incident to war the
continual effort and alarm attendant on
a state of continual danger will compel
nations the most attached to Liberty to
resort for repose and security to
institutions which have a tendency to
destroy their civil and political rights
to be more safe they at length become
willing to run the risk of being less
free and he says that while standing
armies are contemplated by the
Constitution with the lack of a
constitution they become certain he says
frequency of invasion will make people
less likely to protest lack of Liberty
ray says there's a wide difference
between military establishments in a
country seldom exposed by its situation
to internal invasions and in one in
which it is often subject to them and
always apprehensive of them so this is
Alexander Hamilton's excuse for why we
need one country not many constant war
or the threat of constant war would make
it very difficult for the United States
to survive as a free country so that's
basically Alexander Hamilton's argument
there okay so I want to break here on
Facebook and YouTube but when we
continue I'm gonna do some things I like
and then some things that I hate and it
will be just grant you will love every
second of it but for that you're gonna
have to go over and subscribe so for
$9.99 a month you get a subscription to
daily wire comm when you get that
subscription you get along with it the
rest of my show live on video you get
the rest of Michael Noel's a show live
on video the rest of Andrew Clayton's
show live on video you get all of our
special extras when we have the
conversation we ask questions to me you
can ask them live and I will answer them
for you we do that every Friday as well
on our mailbag on the show if you want
the annual subscription you get all of
those things plus the world's greatest
tumbler the leftist year's hot or cold
tumbler makes a great Christmas gift so
make sure that you get the subscription
right now you will enjoy every moment
with this tumbler you'll treasure it
you'll take it to bed with you it is
just the the greatest thing many have
ever experienced I'm not going to say
everyone who's ever tried it has has
lived a long and happy life but I will
say that that's true for at least 100
percent of
people so we will you know just get they
got the copy ole enjoy I promise also if
you want to listen later go to iTunes
SoundCloud make sure that you leave us
review we always appreciate it subscribe
to our YouTube channel we do have a
Christmas video that should be coming
out in the near future that is that
coming out this week Austin yeah so this
week we have a Christmas video that you
are not going to want to miss I wish I
could miss it unfortunately that is not
in fact the case so you will you'll see
that later this week if you subscribe
over at YouTube so become a subscriber
there we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate I
wanted to leave a lot of time for things
I like and things I hate because I have
many a thought on Star Wars and so I'm
again going to reverse this so instead
of doing the things I like first and
then the things that I hate I'm gonna do
things I hate first and then the things
that I like because I have a sort of
like hate thing about Star Wars but I
want to do that last because if people
don't want it spoiled if you're gonna go
see it this weekend I want you to have
the ability to tune out right before I
do my giant Star Wars review okay so I'm
not gonna spoil it for you all of our
producers have seen it so I'm not
spoiling it for them they've all seen it
so I'm not spoiling it for all those
people but I'm gonna say all the I'll do
the entire show that will get to my Star
Wars review and for people who want to
stick around for that then you know you
won't be threatened by spoilers okay so
first the thing that I hate so there's
this insane story that has now come out
about an entire transgender family it's
a local news station in Arizona they've
run a glowing piece on a family that is
in transition as in the whole family so
you've got Daniel Herot the father of
the family a 41 year old biological
female who identifies as a man and then
there's Daniels daughter Mason an 11
year old biological female who now
identifies as a boy and his son Josh a
13 year old biological male who
identifies as a girl Hey Herod's fiance
is also transgender Shirley Austin is a
biological male described as tall and
blond and smiley who claims to be a
woman so in this picture you can see the
the blonde woman is a man the black
haired man is a woman the boy wearing
the black shirt is a girl and the girl
wearing the white shirt is a boy right
this is the this is the case that they
are now making okay so I have my doubts
let me just suggest I have my doubts
that all of this is entirely genetic
okay and there's this argument that's
been made that everyone who is
transgender there must be some genetic
factor that turns everyone transgender
the idea that everyone in this family is
transgender and there is no
environmental impact that a parent
deciding that sex is arbitrary and can
be changed that has no impact on kids
it's just insane to me in the same way
that the suggestion that sexual
orientation is completely genetic I'll
admit that I think part of it is genetic
but the idea that all of sexual
orientation is completely genetic I find
completely unconvincing particularly
because identical twins are not one
percent of the time either gay or
straight it's only about 50% of
identical twins who are both gay or both
the we're both twins are gay
meaning that very often identical twins
who are biologically identical one twin
is gay and one twin is straight which
means there is an environmental
component in this the point here is that
if you have people who are preaching to
their children that sex is completely
malleable and that a boy can be a girl
in a girl came--it boy this might be
confusing to children and it might be
damaging to children because making a
child gender dysphoria may having a
tightening the chances your child is
gonna suffer from gender identity
disorder does not make their life easier
it makes it significantly worse and
harder the reality is that maybe these
kids are gay right sixteen and ninety
percent of all kids who identify as
transgender grow out of it and most of
them identify as gay or lesbian in the
future but the idea that this entire
family is just genetically gay I mean or
rather just genetically transgender I
find very hard to to credit if that were
the case transgenderism I assume would
be a much wider phenomenon and it is not
statistically speaking Josh says he was
six or seven when he knew as a girl I
mean I do wonder at what point Josh
found out that that his that his mother
was in fact his father and the Daniel
says that she knew she was trans quote
last year Joshua wanted to join the Girl
Scouts despite being raised a boy that's
when Daniel was introduced to a word he
never heard before transgender when I
finally looked it up I realized oh my
gosh they're trans and I know it's true
because I am too and it's been my whole
life amazing how it never occurred to
you until it turns out that other people
in your family did that and just then it
this is not confusing children is is
cruel confusing children is evil
pretending that sex is completely
malleable is evil and to subject
children to this sort of activity is is
risky at best and and harmful at worst
okay so time for some things that I like
so here it is folks your spoiler warning
okay we've done your spoiler warning you
have been warned
and there's nothing I can do about it
now if you've decided to go this far
you're gonna go with us the rest of the
way so here's the preface here's a
little bit of the preview for Star Wars
the last Jedi and then I have many a
thought many a thought indeed
when I found you I saw raw untamed power
and beyond that
something truly special
[Applause]
[Music]
or something
like me has always been
okay so when we first let when we last
left off our Sodom just to recap we left
off the force awakens so you can stop
the preview there when we've when we
left the force awakens
Ray had randomly been amazing at
everything she was the ultimate Mary Sue
in science fiction literature she
literally came out of nowhere and was
incredible with a lightsaber so such
that kylo Ren who's supposed to be a guy
trading in his youth for about the force
trained in using a lightsaber it gets
defeated by her in a lightsaber battle
the first time she's literally ever
picked up a lightsaber which is I'm
stupid okay and then they defeated the
Starkiller base which was the new Death
Star because every other movie we have
to have a new Death Star because no one
ever has a practical new idea in the
Star Wars universe apparently okay and
and so we start off this movie and
basically it's as though the force
awakened never happened essentially the
first order is still extraordinarily
powerful Reds in the new Empire they're
still extraordinarily powerful it didn't
matter to them at all that their Death
Star got blown up nothing matters and
the Rebel Alliance is on the run so it's
like Return of the Jedi and it's like
the entire Star Wars series never
happened right the Empire was never
defeated we're basically starting from
the exact same point we started in
Episode four where the Empire is in
control and they and literally it is the
beginning of Star Wars Episode four
right I mean they're the the Empire ship
is chase it the first-order ship is
chasing this transport vessel it's
literally the beginning of episode four
okay so I'm gonna go through some of my
minor problems with this and then I will
go through some of my major problems so
I'll go through my bad things about this
movie and my good things about this
movie so again the first bad thing is
the force awakens apparently never
happened I'd be fine with that I didn't
like the force awakens I thought that it
was a cheesy recasting my biggest
problem with with the entire series is
what they can't decide in Star Wars land
whether they want it to benefit from
nostalgia or they want to make it an
astrologist centric series or they
wanted to launch something new and so
they decided to do both and what they
ended up doing in the process was
killing all of the old things and in
preparation for the new and that's nasty
to my childhood okay I come from the
nostalgia because I thought that the
first you know the the new episodes that
George Lucas made were terrible the
stuff I like is episode four five six
right the stuff that everybody likes is
is new hope Empire Strikes Back Return
of the Jedi couldn't care less about
Phantom Menace or Revenge of the Sith or
any of that crap yeah four five and six
and where it's at so
I grew up with Han Solo I grew up with
Luke Skywalker I grew up with Princess
Leia in fact my sister's middle name one
of my sisters middle names is Leia
because I was such a big Star Wars man
because my parents asked me what I
thought her middle name should be and I
picked Lee up because that was a big
star Wars fan okay so I am a huge Star
Wars nut in the last movie they killed
off Han Solo for no reason they turned
Han Solo who is one of the coolest most
roguish figures who becomes honorable in
thin film or they turned him into a
loser single dad who can't hold his crap
together and gets killed by his whiny
brat son for no reason at all I hate
like when I remember leaving the theater
from the force awakens and thinking oh
that wasn't so bad and then the more I
thought about it the more it made me
want to tear my own teeth out it was
just it so if the force awakens had
never really happened I'd be a much
happier camper also Han would be alive
which would be a lot better okay so it
starts with that then it's then the
force awakens again ends with the idea
that the first-order might finally be on
the run a little bit they are not at all
so okay number two these are minor
problems but there are some like basic
kind of whole plot holes it starts off
with these bombers right these bombers
that bomb a dreadnought and the Bombers
apparently gravity applies in space
which is weird like they actually just
drop bombs onto the Dreadnought in space
so unless there's an actual
gravitational field which I assume would
be pulling the the bombers toward the
dread-nots which they're not I don't
understand how the bombs fall down onto
the onto the dread-nots it doesn't make
any sense to me that is one problem that
that problem is also accompanied by
another problem that is a logistical one
near the end of the film one of the good
people Laura turned in a bizarre turn
decides that she is going to run a
transport vessel through a Star
Destroyer using Lightspeed it's a cool
image why has no one ever thought of
this in the history of Star Wars
especially because if you recall and
returned the Jedi there is an actual
scene where I started a story goes down
because someone does is kamikaze run
right on the Star Destroyer remember
this
returning the Jedi one of the ships kind
of flies out of control boom goes right
through the control tower and down goes
the entire Star Destroyer why's no never
thought to use Star em to use Lightspeed
as a weapon you could just get rid of
the entire first scene or if they knew
that Lightspeed was usable as
weapon why would they sacrifice a couple
of medical ships right there's a point
earlier in the film where a couple of
ships are they they basically run out of
gas and they're blown apart by the first
order if they know they have this tactic
available why don't you turn one of
those ships around and run it with light
speed right through the Star Destroyer
like this is the ultimate weapon in the
universe you could take down the Death
Star this way but apparently this has
never occurred to anyone until laura
dern in her purple hair okay
another problem Snoke okay so they make
Snoke out to be the big baddie in the
force awakens and they make it he's the
he's the big baddie
he's the scary guy he's the new Emperor
and he's so powerful in the forest that
he can turn kylo Ren from afar right
never be meets kylo Ren and he turns
kylo Ren away from Luke that's how
powerful he is and this film they showed
that he's super powerful because Rey is
super power from the forest and he's
like throwing around like nothing right
he just stops her from doing anything
right he's super duper powerful you
never find out who he is you never find
out what motivates him you never find
out where he came from and he gets
killed like that right he gets killed as
like a literally a hot knife going
through butter
right they who literally gets killed
with a little trick by kylo Ren that is
so cheesy and silly that it makes very
little sense it makes sense and return
to the Jedi right it's it they have an
exact Return of the Jedi scene where you
have the good guy and the bad guy and
they're both in front of the Emperor now
in Return of the Jedi it makes sense the
Emperor says to Luke take up your your
take up your lightsabers strike me down
you'll become more powerful than you can
possibly imagine Luke does it and Darth
Vader stops him right that's cool and
it's dramatic here kylo Ren basically
just activates it with his mind somebody
equipped if only they had lightsaber
trigger control this never would have
happened if only the NRA had not stumped
for for for no gun locks on the on the
lightsabers then Snoke would still be
alive but the big problem is of course
you can't build up a big baddie like
that and they not tell him and tell us
who he is or why he's there fourth
problem kylo Ren who is now the only
interesting character left in the Star
Wars universe because they've killed
everyone is not intimidating this is not
a problem with this film this is a
problem with the force awakens in the
force awakens remember it takes Darth
Vader three films three to lose a battle
or to be convertible to the light side
it takes him three films the first thing
you see is Darth Vader is him literally
blowing up
and strangling somebody picking them up
off the ground and strangling him then
he dispatches Luke the most powerful
Jedi in history he dispatches Luke by
chopping off his hand and beating the
crap out of him and umpire strikes back
right and he's basically beating Luke in
Return of the Jedi until Luke basically
taps into the dark side of the force
so it takes him three movies to get
there kylo Ren in the first five minutes
of the force awakens we find out it's
conflicted and then it turns out he can
be bested by Rey the ultimate MarySue
which means he's not scary if you're
gonna have someone scary heading up the
first order that person can't be
defeated by a girl who just picked up a
lightsaber for the first time ever now
if you want to say the girl trained in
it fine but she didn't train in it she
just picked up and she's fantastic at it
why exactly at this point in the film at
this point in the series why should the
Rebel Alliance be worried look I don't
know where they go for episode 9 why
should they be worried Rey is
significantly more powerful than kylo we
know this we've seen it so where's the
competition now no clue right and
general Hux is not exactly terrifying
like general Hux is not the emperor okay
another problem Ray's backstory is
terrible
now I understand what they're trying to
do they're trying to make up for the
fact this movie I feel bad for Ian
Johnson the director and the writer
because I feel like who's trying to make
up for flaws and the other movies so in
this movie with Rey they were basically
trying to cure one of the problems that
was created by George Lucas with his
stupid-ass midi-chlorians nonsense right
so George Lucas had this whole thing
about you know that the forest runs in
your bloodline and this is how we know
that you're powerful with the force and
all this kind of stuff it was always
done well the problem here is that they
made a big deal out of the last movie
what who is Rey where did she come from
and it seems like for some reason she
knows Han right there's there's this
weird kind of relationship where you
remember this Austin it seems like she
knows Han in the force awakens it seems
like everybody sort of knows who she is
but then it turns out that she's just
some girl from middle of nowhere which
would have been fine except you built it
up like there was something interesting
about her background so you picked
literally the least interesting
background for her that you could find
and then you and I understand what
you're trying to do you're trying to
make it that everyone can be
participants in the force we're trying
to get out of Plato's Republic where
there are gradations of human and into
the the Democrat the Democratic Society
where everyone can be a Jedi I get it I
get it but it's not dramatic and then
your real way okay
another problem III didn't need that
entire scene of Luke like milking a sea
cow that was just weird
oh yeah I just think it was just weird
and gross and I wasn't I wasn't big on
it but a bigger prom with Luke is it
Luke happens to be an incredibly crappy
teacher so Luke actually he's making a
good point the Jedi do suck in
everything okay the Jedi were involved
in the original creation of the Empire
the Jedi did fail to stop the Sith they
basically emboldened the Sith the Jedi
were not particularly successful at
maintaining the Republic so they stunk
in everything so Luke is right about
this but he's also a bad teacher right
Rey comes and she says I'm gonna offer
you three lessons the first lesson is
the force exists the second lesson is
feel this rock and there is no third
lesson right not a good teacher that
that guy gets a bad review on college
professors calm okay and also Yoda
showing up I wasn't mad okay another
problem celebrity cameos as I mentioned
before Lordran with purple hair no and
Benicio del Toro my god man okay which
brings us to that entire storyline no no
that entire storyline no okay that's an
entire stupid storyline Laura Dern's
character could have just told Poe
Dameron guess what we're gonna send a
bunch of transports to this random
planet could they not have just done
that instead she pretends like she
doesn't like she has no plan it's kind
of evil and then what happens is that
Poe comes up with some stupid plan to go
to to go to like intergalactic Monte
Carlo with weird creatures that looks
like it's from Harry Potter and their
weird dog rabbits that run around camel
horses that run around also we can get a
bunch of social justice warrior crap
about income inequality and animal
rights
there was the line in this movie so bad
that I legitimately was thinking about
walking out of the theater and there's a
line in this movie we're after Finn who
is useless right he is useless and Rose
who is double useless they go to this
stupid planet and then they free the
animals who have been abused oh this is
how we know the rebels are good guys
because they don't like animals being
abused right okay great okay this is a
far cry by the way from Empire Strikes
Back where Han literally cuts open the
belly of a what is it a tauntaun thank
you and stuffs Luke inside right but now
we have to make sure that all of the
rights of the animals are upheld because
this is deeply important listen I'm for
animal rights but what does Star Wars
have to do the animal
it's like what the hell and they and and
fin turns to Rose and he says well I
guess it was worth it
you mean losing the entire galaxy was
worth you going there to free a few
camel horses that will be recaptured
five seconds from now was that the thing
that was worth it and then the worst
line in the film Rose turns to him she
takes a saddle off the camel horse dog
and she goes now it's worth it what no
it's not like it's not like your whole
job here is to get this gal that this
this hacker guys he can go back to fake
Death Star and hack the program no no no
no no no also it should have killed Finn
okay when Finn is riding at the end
directly toward that that giant blaster
weapon sword the battering ram he should
have just died okay he they should have
killed him at the end of force awakens
to add some gravitas this is my biggest
problem they will not kill any of the
new characters because they're trying to
preserve the new characters instead they
kill all of the old cool characters who
I actually like I don't like Finn he's
boring I don't care about rose she's
boring
Wray is only not boring because she has
interactions with kylo Ren okay everyone
is boring in the new city in the new
scenario and they're killing off all of
the cool characters who made this thing
into a legacy in the first place which
brings me to Rose don't even get me
started
no no no no no okay fine okay Captain
phasma also like what she's supposed to
be a thing
well good cuz she wasn't a thing okay
Captain phasma was it like she's there
for five seconds she's dressed up as as
you know it's Brienne of Tarth too
dressed as Bubba Fett he's must be so
cool Finn the janitor takes her out fail
oh yeah and a few more criticism then
I'll get some good stuff okay so the
credit wasn't one of criticism at Luke
the best moments in the movie aside from
the the kylo Ren the the kylo Ren Rey
team-up which is the best part of the
movie aside from that the best moments
of the movie is the part where Luke
strides out of the of the cave and kylo
Ren has every 8080 fire on him and then
Luke just walks right out of it right
super cool they then destroy the
coolness of this moment by having it be
basically a hologram right he's using
astral projection from because he's
still back at stupid planet why would
you do that
how'd you do that the entire coolness of
it is that he's actually there stopping
the blasters it's not cool if they're
just shooting a hologram cuz Holograms
can't be damaged we all know that why
would you do that
so in one case we know so the force is
used in two ways in this film that we've
never seen it used before and we'll
never see it used again one it
apparently protects you from space death
so Princess Leia gets blown out into
space she's never used the force at all
that we've seen except for one time when
she used her mind to reach out to Luke's
mind at the end of Empire and now she
can suddenly rescue herself from space
and fly which is a cool thing I guess
like I didn't know this was the thing
also if that were a thing why wouldn't
the Emperor use it at the Empire at the
end of Return of the Jedi
alright Luke Darth Vader literally takes
the Emperor and throws him down a
wormhole sandy throws him down the shaft
the Maya shaft right why wouldn't if he
can flow I wouldn't just float I'm so
confused by this okay so that is one
fourth thing that we didn't know about a
second force thing we didn't know about
is this astral projection nonsense it's
so much cooler if Luke is actually there
and we and there's precedent for right
you could actually build that in because
an empire you recall there's a point
where Han Solo is invited by Lando to
dine with Darth Vader and he takes out
his blaster and he shoots star fader and
so our favor goes like this and stops
the blaster you remember this so Luke is
significantly more powerful than Darth
how much more powerful well we would
find out if they were actually there and
he stopped a bunch of athe barrage right
that'd be amazing that's true kylo does
do that in force awakens kylo does stop
a blaster in force awakens that's
correct
he stops it in the air right then he
stopped so kylo can do it but Luke has
to be a hologram why why why okay
finally this is the biggest problem
kylo should have sided with Rey okay if
you're gonna do something new you cannot
just redo the original trilogy by having
kylo be Darth Vader he's just like
Anakin he was conflicted and now he's
bad and Ray's always good and you can't
do that they were building up for this
too right like there's a point where
Luke explicitly says that Rey does not
resist the dark side maybe there was a
point where he says that anything okay
well maybe the dark side in the light
side are actually one force right
there's this theory in the Star Wars
universe and then there's that great
moment where kylo and and Rey team up
and you think this is changing the
entire nature of the Star Wars universe
right you've never seen this before
the only team
you've ever seen is when Darth Vader
makes a final decision right before he
dies to toss the Emperor down the
mineshaft
that's the only time you've seen this in
Star Wars universe and it's super cool
right when I was in the theater it's
packed theater on Saturday night and the
audience burst into applause all right
the audience started applauding everyone
was blown away by that scene right it's
a great scene all the way up to and
including the whole thing where we're
ray tosses him the lightsaber he goes
doom and activates it right through the
guy's face right dad the whole scene is
great and then you immediately blow it
then you immediately blow it because
there's no real motivation for kylo to
say let the transports all be wiped out
still there's no motivation there who
cares five seconds before this he
refused to fire on his mother
five seconds right he's not the one who
blew princess lay out into space he
refused to do it so why does he want to
kill her now now he wants to kill her
doesn't make any sense
so that's all the criticism here's
what's right with the film number one it
is better than the force awakens okay
the force awakens for me was was just a
disaster all the way through the reason
being that again they took han Solo and
made him uncool Luke doesn't end up on
coolness in this thing he Lucas cool I
just think that his death is a little
wasted second the kylo Ren connection
really works this was something I didn't
expect going into the film I thought a
kylo hey ray but the kylo Ren connection
they actually have some chemistry
on-screen and every scene where they're
basically skyping in to each other all
those scenes really work and the scene
in the throne room really works the
scene where they're working together
that's the coolest part and that's why
you don't want it to end and that's why
when it does end you're annoyed because
they just went back to same old same old
okay that lightsaber battle also works
right that lightsaber battle is one that
really that scene is one of the best
scenes in all of Star Wars Canon right
that one scene I'm not saying the movie
I'm saying that one scene is one of the
best things in all of Star Wars Canon
where where kylo turns and suddenly he
and Ray are on the same side it's really
cathartic and it's really cool and
finally the final thing that works is
Luke's final fade-out works just because
it's a throwback he gets it he actually
gets a death that I guess is is
deserving a lot better than Han right
Han just gets stabbed through the belly
and thrown down another one of these
incessant mine shafts that seemed to be
everywhere in Star Wars universe but
Luke actually gets to do the final
Tatooine two sons right gazing off into
the distance thing and that works and
it's emotionally resonant I just wish
you weren't dead because I think
that then it was a wasted death they
should have ended the film probably
after the Kyllo racing and they should
have made the entire final part of that
movie the third movie right that's
that's probably what they should have
done okay so is it worth seeing well if
you've watched this far you've already
seen it because you've heard all the
spoilers but my biggest problem now is
that I actually think this is the end of
the Star Wars universe I think this is
actually where it's I think that this is
the end of where Star Wars can go
because now all the old characters are
dead we've reached the end of the
Skywalker family essentially like Ben's
Solo is a thing I guess but kylo is his
own sort of character and they're gonna
kill kylo in the next film for sure so
why would I show up to watch a movie
without Luke Leia is dead right in real
life
Carrie Fisher is dead they Han is dead
what what are they where are they gonna
go from here that's not just gonna be
more typical light side versus dark side
stuff they were on the verge of doing
something so great this is what annoys
me they were so close to doing something
unprecedented right let's say that Rey
actually that it kylo says you know what
you're right and he calls off the attack
hey sister right we're gonna rule the
galaxy together and that's the end of
the film and you don't know what's gonna
happen
how's Leia gonna respond to this how
Luke's gonna respond to this especially
since kylo as you recall just killed Han
right wouldn't they like where would it
go
it sets up all these possibilities
instead we're thrust back into sort of
this binary universe where okay guess
Poe Dameron is gonna take over for
Carrie Fisher is the head of thee as the
head of the the rebellion and and Rey is
gonna be the new Luke and kylo is gonna
be the new Darth and yeah so I guess
this sort of ends the Canon but it did
have some moments it did have so okay so
there is my full take I think that's
pretty fulsome take on Star Wars and if
you have thoughts on that you're always
free to email me or tweet me and tell me
that I am wrong but we'll be back here
at tomorrow the Republicans are set to
vote on taxes tomorrow so that will be
interesting we'll give you all the
details I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex zingaro audio is mixed by
Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by Jess
well para the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing